so despite the witcher 3 wild hunts near
universal praise CD Projekt RED believes
that the game's upcoming expansion is
even better than the main game in an
interview with Eurogamer italy the
witcher 3 senior writer talked about the
game's upcoming expansion called blood
and wine apparently the expansion will
conclude protagonist garold story and
include a more charismatic opponent this
time around I'm blood and Weinstein page
the description gives us a hint at what
we might encounter in the expansion it
says blood and wine a 20-hour tale that
will introduce the all-new in-game
region of Tucson we'll take Darryl to a
land untainted by war where an
atmosphere of carefree indulgence and
nightly ritual masks an ancient bloody
secret blood and wine is scheduled to
release in the first half of 2016 but
little else is known about Gareth next
adventure we reached out to CD Projekt
RED for further updates so in the
meantime stay tuned to gamespot com for
more news on The Witcher 3